there are a lot of us
all with different cultures languages
beliefs so yeah communication
it's not always easy you're crazy you're
crazy you're crazy but
no matter where we come from or the
languages we speak
by using these we can still connect with
other humans
and now maybe with them too
[Applause]
there are so many purposes of facial
expressions
i'm david matsumoto i'm a professor of
psychology at san francisco state
university
and i'm also director of human tell the
face is one of the most complex
signal systems we have in the body and
it serves many purposes
for example when we wrinkle our nose in
disgust
like this not only is it communicating
something to you who can perceive my
expression what it's also doing is
clamping down a little bit on those
nasal passages it's preventing
things from coming into my body through
my nasal passage
facial expressions also communicate to
the people around us
one of the biggest advocates for this
theory charles darwin darwin
posited that all humans have emotions
it allows us to act immediately with
minimal
conscious thinking or awareness and then
on top of that
we had these expressions so that we
could communicate
that reaction to others as well and that
helped
the group to survive because of this
darwin believed our expressions were
universal
so in psychology today there is
widespread agreement
that seven facial expressions of emotion
are universally recognized
all around the world regardless of race
color creed nationality gender
any demographic that exists
they are anger contempt disgust
fear happiness sadness and surprise
[Music]
so this means as humans we can talk to
each other
even without words
but can facial expressions help us
connect with human-like technology
so the robot is a way to understand
human self for me right by creating a
very human-like robot i believe
that we can get there some knowledge
about the humans
my name is hiroshi suguru i'm a
roboticist
what i could run through the are robots
so many things right we are trying to
develop
interactive robots with humans
[Applause]
[Music]
and we study how the human can interact
with the robots
so not to develop that kind of robot the
very special expressions
and gazing directions getting control of
the robot is
very important right the robot needs to
represent
the emotions and intelligence in many
ways
we we have a totally different culture
between the united states and in japan
right but
you know that we understand emotional
expression there is no doubt
emotional racial expression is a very
important way of
communication so therefore you know the
uh occasional expression is a very
important good
android for having the communication
with the human
my name is erica me erica
i think erica is the most human-like
android in the world
erica can have a you know kind of a
natural conversation with
the visitors maybe the five or ten
minutes
uh we are implementing the uh maybe you
know just
major uh the facial expression to the
erica
right happy very exciting angry
[Music]
the android can have you know their
communications
by exchanging the facial expressions
even if android
doesn't understand the language there
are so many great applications for these
robots whether it's helping the elderly
guiding tourists or even for
entertainment it's all very exciting
oh sorry about that i got a little
carried away
by designing robots to have facial
expressions humans could more easily
connect with them
and incorporate them into our lives it's
just really interesting because
we we use our faces to reference
many different mental states by
expressing the facial expression
even if we don't understand our language
each other
like we can we can be assured some
information
and because of that facial expressions
of emotion are the closest thing we have
to a universal language
they allow us to share emotions with
each other
they allow us to share the time when we
laugh together or cry together if
there's anything out there
they're the single most important
vehicle that we have that can bring us
all together
[Music]
[Music]
you